bro you went to the bathroom for five
minutes are you serious
come on now
listen i have never taken
such a fast
piss
in my whole life and sometimes when you
gotta go you gotta go even when you're
at the grammys i what i needed to i had
so much champagne dosiacat nearly missed
the chance to accept her award when she
won best pop duo group performance for
her song with scizza kiss me more
[Music]
but dozia's bathroom break wasn't the
only unexpected moment here sizza also
surprised everyone when she popped out
of her seat and scooted to the stage
using crutches and wearing high heels no
less it also doesn't hurt to get an
assist from lady gaga and by the time
the singer took the stage the big
question on everyone's mind where's
dosia bro you went to the bathroom for
five minutes are you serious
come on now
listen i have never taken
such a fast
piss
in my whole life
[Applause]
thank you
everybody
it's a moment the ceso singer went into
detail about with e.t backstage so
explain to me the bathroom you were
going to the bathroom um i
i needed to i had so much champagne
there were so many performances that
were amazing and you have to toast and
you're like you go you
and you're performing whatever anyway i
was drinking a lot the one moment that i
went to go it just it it was my time and
then a woman ran into the bathroom and i
got god i don't remember her name but
she she grabbed me by my wrist yanked me
out and i was like i've never been
pulled so strongly in my life and it was
like the end of the world it felt like
but she pulled me and i ran for my life
it was beautiful and
i got to the stage i threw my
vape and i got on there and i did my
thing but yeah i know i was definitely
in the middle of a big piss
there's some miscellaneous woman who
saved the world tonight yeah she did and
i wish i knew her name
she deserves credit and in the end it
was all worth it because the win was an
emotional one i like to downplay
but this is a
it's a big deal
i'm good at
closing those emotions closing those
the reality of how i feel in
and
so so i think tonight was one of those
nights where
it kind of came out in a way where no
one's ever uh
been able to kind of see it i'm very
very happy i'm excited i'm
i'm blessed and it means a lot to me
and it means a lot to my team and i
think that that's why
it kind of hit me so hard because
it was
something that we all
imagined in the beginning
[Music]
you